there's this misconception that because
something is natural it's safer I would
not say that this is safe by any means
and just because it's natural doesn't
mean it's safe in addition just because
you can't see it doesn't mean it's safe
so to get to this kind of haze that
we're seeing on screen you have to have
very high concentrations of this kind of
air pollution in the air each of these
particles we call them PM 2.5 they're
less than 2.5 micrometers in diameter so
less than a tenth the size of a human
hair those are tiny and so those can get
deep inside the lungs cause inflammation
and but that's also why you need so much
of it to be able to see it